tu es ce qu'on apporte ça ça c'est toute
la famille
c'est jour de grand chambardement pour
pierre girard après 55 ans de vie
commune
sa femme micheline quitte la maison fac
et nous avons organisé une rencontre
avec le pape
deux catholiques pratiquants mariés pour
le meilleur et pour le pire mais qui
doivent maintenant se séparer à cause de
la maladie
lorsque m quel ma demande c'est qui toi
ce que j'ai je fascine regarde la photo
on est mariés ensemble tellement content
d'être mariée avec toi micheline
souffrait d'alzheimer
pierre doit se résigner à la place et
familles et amis des ménages ces
affaires micheline quitte sa maison sans
comprendre qu'il n'y reviendra jamais
après toute une vie passée à ses côtés
pierre appréhende déjà la solitude si
sharp a pas de bons jours plus tard ce
jour l'un pierre et son fils martin
accompagne micheline à la maison au
campanile financée par des dons et des
subventions de québec
la résidence est conçu expressément pour
les gens atteints dans un mois premier
objectif ralentir la progression de la
maladie avec des activités
il n'y a pas de fumée sans et la maison
est aménagé pour limiter l angoisse des
résidents la dame qui habite ci a
apporté son lit les bureaux donc c'est
tout son mobilier ce qui fait que l des
points de repères par rapport à sa vie
antérieure
la maison au campanile est un lieu à
dimension humaine seulement 22 résidents
qui vivent dans trois petites unités
ils sont 8 au deuxième étage dans les
montées la maison verte et la cuisine
les gens m'ont fait aller déjeuner avec
la table comment la maison on est frappé
ici par le calme des lieux et des gens
madame laroche petite collation entre
autres parce que le personnel est assez
nombreux on est deux intervenants pour
le président des intervenants ça veut
dire qu'on a vraiment du temps on prend
du temps avec eux mêmes pour les soins
on prend du temps pour jaser un peu avec
eux presque deux fois plus de personnel
par résident que ce que l'on retrouve
ailleurs des employés à qui on offre en
plus une formation appropriée
ça peut aller même jusqu'à trente ans de
formation sans maladie d'hazard pour les
employés donc la communication la
maladie en pack tels le cerveau comment
on intervient parce que malgré les
visites de sa famille intégrer les
résidents comme mechs lennon est souvent
très complexes
nous la retrouvons fin janvier plus de
quatre mois après son arrivée des mois
ponctuée de périodes difficiles
la micheline a retrouvé le sourire et
dit être attaché à sa nouvelle demeure
bien belle je peux pour déménager dans
la clarté colloque qui devient de lol
mais la maladie progresse micheline que
je connais depuis 35 ans ne me reconnais
plus ça a été bien agréable de vous
rencontrer pour pierre cette séparation
forcée est difficile
[Musique]
c'est maintenant au tour de l'ain la
société alzheimer rive-sud lui offre un
accompagnement professionnel qui a
débuté plusieurs mois avant l'arrivée de
sa famille ici donc 22 personnes qui
habitent ici à 22 familles qu'on
accompagne mais dans une année c'est
1200 personnes à une prochaine d'un qui
vont accuser l'ensemble de nos services
micheline s'enracine dans sa nouvelle
demeure et pierre lui doit faire le
deuil de leur ancienne vie la maison
lévis saint michel
[Musique]